many many scientists I knew were unhappy
with the lockdowns who were afraid to
say speak up many people weren't
comfortable with lockdowns but afraid to
scientists afraid to speak up yeah okay
well I mean you have people like Tony
facci who controls you know tens of
billions of dollars of funding for
scientists but and you're actually not
just the funding
um I I guess it's like Francis Collins
the head of the NIH the reason the
reason is they also control the social
status of scientists yeah you can't run
your you can't run your experiments you
don't get NIH funding actually you don't
get you don't get tenure at Big
universities
um so it's it's it's uh it's it's almost
like career suicide speaking up when
someone like Francis Collins or Tony
fauci says no no you can't uh that we we
have to do this we have to do the
lockdown